[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka the guy who's gonna
cry now
because it seems like my damn door is
gonna get fixed before we get this
spider-man no way home trailer
fear not though as i've been sent some
brand new exclusive
exclusive plot leaks that tell us some
cool details about the upcoming marvel
movie
throughout this video we're going to be
going through what's apparently in the
film and how it confirms
some of the things we already know i'll
also be going over the first look at
christian bales gore the butcher and
thor love and thunder
whilst discussing how many gods he had
to butcher in order to prepare for the
role
full spoilers ahead and whilst we won't
know if these leaks are true until the
movie releases
they do line up a lot with what have
been shown of behind the scenes stuff
if you will and a friend then thumbs up
the video and don't forget to subscribe
to stick around for breakdowns on the
web every day
without the way thank you for clicking
this now let's get into spiderman no way
home
okay so as i mentioned up top i can't
confirm if these are true or not
but they were sent with certain
materials that makes me think they're
legitimate
you never know whether studios will let
you do videos on this kind of stuff or
not
and therefore i'd rather just keep
things as safe as possible
and say that my source is definitely not
my uncle who works at the sony store in
eldon square
it's it it's not him i promise now when
the trailer eventually drops we'll know
whether these are true
but as you know with me i rarely do big
plot league breakdowns unless i'm fairly
confident that the majority of it is
accurate
now the movie apparently opens
immediately after the events of
spider-man far from home
we pick up with the focus on a sign that
says west 33rd street
and after googling this our source
located opposite pennsylvania station
which is where peter was at during the
post-credits scene of the prior movie
he jumps down to talk to mj and is
immediately swamped by the public
who are all recording him on their
phones and posting out his reaction
this makes him panic and he grabs mj
before swinging through the city
this includes traveling past times
square which has his face apparently
blown up on the central screen
not long after this peter hands himself
in and he's joined at the station by mj
ned and also flash flash was of course a
big fan of spider-man
but he hated penis parker and used to
bully him at school
however realizing that he's a good guy
he joins his side
and interestingly the actor has now
apparently dyed his hair bleach blonde
which lines up more with his comic book
counterpart according to what i've been
told
peter even allows himself to be put in
one handcuff whilst the other one is
tied to an interrogation room table
he could clearly snap out of this but
he's meant to do it so that the officers
feel safe
similar to how supes did in man of steel
now after carrying out a proper
investigation
and also going through the courts with
matt murdock as his lawyer
people quickly realized that the
mysterio group was fake news in the
murder of quentin beck
and peter's name is cleared however the
world knows that he's spider-man
and thus he gets mobbed in school and
also can't really live a normal life
there's meant to be a really touching
scene in which he and mj sit on a
rooftop away from the world
and peter says that he just wants to
stay up there forever during this mj
reads a newspaper
and says the report states that
spider-man has the power to hypnotize
females
which foreshadows a big thing that we'll
be talking about later on in the video
now the pair are absolutely consumed by
the new fan fame and there's meant to be
a lot of scenes early on that have them
reading their phones
and just obsessing over it the movie
also takes place across a number of
seasons
and it's supposed to range from summer
through autumn and
all the way up to winter which we know
from some behind the scenes videos on
the film
now it's during autumn namely halloween
that peter gets a certain idea
after looking at a witch decoration he
apparently gets the idea to go to doctor
strange
and ask for his help peter goes back to
the sanctum sanctorum
and we find it pretty run down and
covered in snow
this is apparently because after bruce
banner came through the roof and left a
hole
everyone got snapped and they're only
now just cleaning it the funko pops do
line up with this
and stranger one can be found shoveling
snow and trying to clear the place out
peter asks strange if it's possible to
go back in time and change
things but as we know this would only
create a branched reality
rather than changing the results of what
really happened this actually pulls from
the one more day storyline
which happened after the events of civil
war in the comics peter revealed that he
was spider-man to the world
in order to show how trustworthy the
superhuman registration act was
but this led to kingpin sending
assassins after him
one tried to kill him but they shot
ant-may instead and peter ended up
traveling to strange for help
similar the movie strange was in a run
down sanctorum
and from what i've been told privately
by dudebro trust me
the movie is pulling heavily from the
comic in its strange reached across the
multiverse
in order to attempt to see if there was
anyone who could help peter
and all the heroes said there was
nothing they could do thus he ended up
turning to mephisto
who said that he would help out but he
wanted his and mj's marriage as payment
to make sure that no one would come
after me again he also erased the
knowledge that peter parker was
spider-man
and though the devil who's in the
details doesn't show up in this film
we do get a similar sort of thing with
strange now because strange corn time
travel
he apparently decides to do a spell that
will erase the knowledge from everyone's
mind that peter is spider-man
wong is meant to warn him not to do it
as it's super dangerous
and strange apparently says he won't do
it but then he gives peter a cheeky wink
wong then packs his bags and he goes off
to fight the abomination in chongqi
and this leaves strange by himself so he
can carry it out
now the detail i was told which will
either make or break these leaks
is that strange apparently has a coffee
mug with for
[ __ ] sake written on it i don't know
why they said that but it was such a
weird detail and what i was sent
that i thought i'd put it in the video
if you're from the future either you
know
you know what's happened and you're
shaking your head at how much of an
idiot i am for saying this
or you're saying that's some other [ __ ]
kevin spoilers he did it again
now from here peter and strange go to
the basement of the sanctum
and strange pulls her hair from peter's
head to create the spell
similar how he did to thor in ragnarok
he then casts it out of the world to
make sure that everyone forgets that
peter is spider-man
however peter interrupts this and asks
if he can keep it so that people who
found out before mysterio revealed it
still know the truth this is because mj
and peter have
a bit of back and forth about how
difficult it was keeping it from her
and he doesn't want to go through that
again this unfortunately cracks the
multiverse wide open
and we get the sinister six coming
through this tear in reality
as we've said in other breakdowns and
league videos the lineup is green goblin
doctor octopus electro lizard sandman
and rhino new york is then apparently
attacked by these villains
and both strange and peter have to round
them up the only one they don't capture
is green goblin
as he decides to hang back whilst the
others go ahead
strange then puts them in a prison which
peter doesn't know about and goblin goes
to visit them
here he finds out that the last thing
they all remember is the spider-man of
their earth being there when they died
goblin can't break them out because
there's a magical cube that strangers
put in place to stop them
and thus he goes to peter for help he
tells him that the peter of their
earth's killed them
and that if they go back they'll face
their death so there's
so there's drum roll please here
no way home now peter feels super guilty
about this and he steals the cube
which leads to strange chasing him
across the city in the mirror dimension
there's apparently a moment which the
city collapses in on itself
similar to how it did in the chase in
strange's solar movie and he uses his
cape to capture peter
you've probably seen that lad piss from
wee-wee films the other day you'll
probably see them
posting that exclusive exclusive photo
he had from the movie
and i'm pretty sure that this happens
just before this moment i've left a link
to his video somewhere if you want to go
watch it
and i'd advise leaving a comment that
trolls him a bit yeah now i i'll i'll
never say go harass another creator
especially not chris as i bloody love
the guy but i wouldn't be mad if
everyone just went there and said
that chris parker is a menace or words
to that effect in your best jay jonah
jameson voice
now strange pushes out his astral form
and manages to get the cube
but it's too late and the villains
escape now that's the majority of the
major new things i got told from my
uncle
the the person who sent me and though
some of it is what we know before
it does flesh out the order of the story
and the way things happen a lot
the person did say the major leaks we've
seen are true
with osborne stealing an arc reactor and
positioning it above the statue of
liberty
which now has a giant captain america
shield on our last plot leak video we
talked about how there was a big
character death
but that we didn't know exactly who this
was i have been told that the studio
actually filmed several different scenes
that won't be used just to keep things
safe from the spectacular spoiler man
tom holland
but that they are leaning into it being
may may was of course
almost killed in one more day so that
makes a lot of sense
and it'll leave some actual consequences
for the ending of this movie
anyway if it turns out to be true then i
think it'll work really well
and it makes way more sense than some of
the 20 000 word leaks that i've seen on
reddit
in regards to the trailer we are getting
to the point now that it should be
released
and if it doesn't come out this month i
think the movie will be delayed
daniel rpk said he thinks it will either
be with shanghi or venom 2
and these both come out in september
therefore it's cutting it super close to
the release date
just three months later if they drop it
then so i really don't know
the let there be carnage trailer did say
coming soon at the end
rather than having a date and thus it
might show that the studio are waiting
to see how things develop
before announcing whether they're doing
it further or not i will of course keep
you posted but no matter what anyone
tells you
no one knows for definite exactly when
it's dropping now before we get into the
christian bale picks i'd obviously love
to hear your thoughts on the leaks so
make sure you drop them below and let me
know
we are giving away three mcu box sets on
the 30th of august
and all you have to do to be on the
chance of winning is give us a thumbs up
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your quick thoughts on the
video
we picked the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now
save that to you then message me on
twitter heavyspoilers now dole live and
thunder is currently being filmed
and our first behind the scenes look at
christian bale have emerged from the set
he is playing gwar the butcher and this
is a bit of a departure from the comic
character
as it doesn't seem like they're leaning
into the alien look unless they use cgi
however if you get christian bale you
tend to want to use all of his acting
abilities
and i think they might keep things as we
see it here and then just use
lighting and shadow to to make him seem
more sinister
now he looks a lot like a statue and i'm
super interested to see how they use him
in the movie
we all know how the last comic book
movies that he was attached to turned
out
and this is a massive deal for marvel so
i really hope that he's properly
utilized in the film
gore is one of the meanest some of the
[ __ ] since clint eastwood
and he travels across the universe
wiping out all gods
due to their disregard for life gore
believes them to be illegitimate rulers
that don't deserve to have the power
that they do
and he certainly doesn't think that he
use it for the good of people he wants
to smash their head in like you should
smash that like button
and i really hope they lean into the
darker side of the character
anyway that's the video yeah get the
hell out of here
and don't tell sony yeah my uncle's on
his second warning
after leaking photos of woody's wig in
venom too and i just don't want the guy
to get in any more trouble
what i do want though is to hear your
thoughts so make sure you drop them
below
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the venom 2 trailer
which will be linked on screen right now
if you don't
there's going to be carnage and i i'd
love it if you went over there and also
said something nice yeah just give me
give me a nice little compliment and
without the way thank you for sitting
through this video
i've been paul i'll see you next time
mate you yeah
you take care of yourself and don't tell
anyone about this conversation we've
just had
peace